seit 13 jahren ist die kleine maddie
mccann verschwunden
ermittler gehen davon aus dass das
mädchen bereits tot ist tat verdächtigt
ist christian b der 43 jährige hatte in
braunschweig unter anderem einen kiosk
und bild hat einen seine stammkunden
getroffen
christian b steht unter verdacht
mellencamp die vor 13 jahren aus seinem
ferienhaus in portugal verschwand
getötet zu haben
der 24-jährige gianmarco die partie kann
sich noch an den mann erinnern der vor
sechs jahren einen kiosk in braunschweig
betrieb er hat meist auf den
dreitagebart also unrasiert ungepflegt
nicht wirklich auf sein aussehen
geachtet sag ich mal so will man
schmutzige schmutzig ist aber kein so
sauber neues hemd getragen
ja so war sein äußeres mit auf jeden
fall
den jugendlichen soll wie auch alkohol
und zigaretten verkauft haben und nicht
nur das ja das ist wir hatten so bekommt
dass er höchstwahrscheinlich aber das
ist jetzt nicht hundertprozentig das hat
wahrscheinlich unter der ladentheke hat
auch gras verkauft bzw mit gras zu tun
hat auf jeden fall
und dass er halt meistens mit welchen
leuten halt im hintergrund da in seinem
laden das war wie so eine art wohnzimmer
dahinter dort drin gesessen hat und hat
dort wartet auf kunden gewartet hat
meinte hat immer das airbus hat wir sind
kaiser wussten damit fährt gern quer
durch durch die weltgeschichte hat der
täter das erfährt gern mal wohin als die
otti von der mutmaßlichen tat aus den
medien erfuhr konnte er das zunächst
kaum glauben
also ich war echt geschockt so das hätte
ich dann merkt man auch wie wie wie
unberechenbar manche menschen sind als
was für gesichter die männchen haben
also sehr dass ich echt geschafft der
mordverdächtige schweigt übrigens zu den
vorwürfen er wolle vorerst keine
stellung beziehen erklärten die anwälte
von christian b schauen wir jetzt nach
kiel dort steht unser bild reporter
thomas knoop vor der jva in kiel dort wo
christian beeck gerade einsetzt thomas
was weiß man über christian b weiß er
von sei von den anschuldigungen gegen
ihn drei strafverteidiger haben sich
mittlerweile für ihn legitimiert die
staatsanwaltschaft sagt mir dass man
ihnen bislang aber noch nicht vernommen
hätte man möchte aus taktischen gründen
die momentan keine einen einblick in die
ermittlungsakten gewähren
christian b sitzt hier in kiel ein wegen
drogenhandel hat mehrere kilo marihuana
auf sylt verkauft wurde dazu verurteilt
zu einer strafe von einem jahr und neun
monaten
die staatsanwaltschaft ist ein bisschen
sozusagen in sorge gerade bei gestern
war zwei drittel der strafe abgelaufen
das landgericht wird jetzt prüfen ob er
vorzeitig frei kommt es gibt allerdings
einen weiteren haftbefehl wegen der
vorurteile vom landgericht braunschweig
geht die vergewaltigung einer rentnerin
72 in portugal und dann würde dieser
neue artikel auf jeden fall greifen und
dann würde aber christian b hier verlegt
werden von der gefängnis in tier die
untersuchung
wir sind denn die haftbedingungen in der
jva hier weißt du dass es gibt 268 8
plätze 150 bedienstete das gebäude wurde
1914 bis 1918 gebaut und es sind hier
eigentlich eher kleinkriminelle die hier
einsetzen
die maximale haftstrafe von drei jahren
absitzen das justizministerium entsteht
so feuchter und mäßig zum teil christian
beeck gar nicht äußern auch nicht die
sein alltag aus